this is what you wanted huh we got it we
got it yeah like a grandma okay we got
it we got it we understand it we
understand it we understand it we get it
we get it
i'm going to go crazy please stop it you
didn't like it
crazy they're tough
[Laughter]
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
yeah it sounds good right holy [ __ ] we
look like we're fine
we're here on k white from tennessee ky
tennessee
like to say the n-word w-h-i-t-t
your netflix special blowing up your
channel is different man yeah big time
now big time mr big time netflix well
that's today right
but it came on it that was yesterday
that was yesterday i thought it was the
19th it just dropped it just dropped i
watched it this morning at 6am that's
what i'm saying it was actually at
midnight okay first
like a mom dude yeah
we gotta see if we can get some
different mom
i'm like a step back if your mom was
like if your mom looked like bro
i want the hot mom with the big tits nah
man that ain't for you how are you
feeling with the special deal eric dude
what would you say b i said how you
feeling with the special
you feel good about it it's always
nerve-wracking when you
put yourself out there like that yeah
you know you know i guess i have some
different thoughts i'm definitely
excited about it um
[Music]
but then you also see what some of the
you know like i don't know there's
different i'm really excited i'm excited
people get to see it that never got to
come out to a comedy show yeah yeah um
there's a lot of energy and hype around
it kind of oh you come out like it's not
like bruce buffer not the same
what's that being i'm sorry i said you
came out like bruce buffer announced
your name he came out the cannon hot
that open scene he come to watch it i
haven't watched it i thought i knew it
was today but i didn't realize i could
have watched it
it's a hot hour boy i think huh you're
burning bro you burn your hands even on
the back end of that thing can i say
something before you even continue theo
you know it's like it's hard to it's
hard for us to come compartmentalize our
brains sometimes
and i think that like you know you
always have like a sort of businessy
side of your brain that's always working
and i think that sometimes you should
turn that off and just enjoy the moment
it's like you did this thing it's great
you have a lot of fans you you've come a
long way so take a time to enjoy it it's
like a nfl team like enjoy the win
on sunday don't look at the next movie
yeah and then wait till monday or
tuesday to be like all right now let's
go on to the next game but make sure you
take some time right now just to enjoy
it and stop because i know your brain is
already thinking about okay there's
critics there's this i got to get this
many views i got to go this and that
don't worry about all that just enjoy
this w today
and then you can worry about all that
businessy [ __ ] later that's good advice
the other thing too is netflix promoting
them too yeah like big time yeah man
when that when i turned on my netflix
this morning boom he's top of the the
promo wow
well there it is right there i just went
to my netflix on my he's on the top
right
boom that's right netflix it was shane
it's because they know we're in the same
room bro you go go down go to the
bathroom you won't even see me on your
thing it'll be like ozarks
or whatever i'm watching i like a lot of
sci-fi stuff black ozark whatever you
watch
somehow i don't know what y'all doing
bro
well look at eric eric's dressed like a
uh brokeback mentos
he said you look like a brokeback mentos
oh listen to him
what do you got a jiu jitsu shirt on
no yeah that's from a boy jack shore
tank shore sent me this oh yeah he looks
like a nascar car friendly
from across the pond baby across the
pond seven people reneged on their
accounts once you they saw you rocking
that shirt doug
bro we don't say reneged in here dude
i think you do actually
no well well
yeah you dropped the re yeah
yeah i can't even believe they got i
mean some of the stuff we gotta you know
if you go to the sushi menu if you had a
sushi place
they got that one item on there i can't
even order it anymore
what the hell's going on
yeah there's certain whiskey i can't
order that japanese one that's spelled
with n-i-k-k-a
yeah what japanese whiskey that he says
yeah that one oh
gotcha i'm just pointing at it dude
i'll just say look you know the one i
want you know what i'm talking about the
ninja jury
i had a question how long in a
comedian's career does it take you to
get to that pinnacle moment of a special
it's like you got to do it 20 years it
took me two weeks two weeks
it took me two weeks in our showtime
special
and now i don't know
i don't advise that no no no no are you
being serious no it's different now
steve it's it's it's a different world
so this is my view on specials we're at
the theo's level and get on netflix
that's a big [ __ ] deal and it took
him years and years and years and feels
one of the most gifted comics in the
world how many years are we talking
about she's been doing 20 [ __ ] years
something like that 20 plus years now
he's at this pinnacle
yeah to to get on netflix where you know
there's it's gonna say chappelle birth
theo segura joe coy
that's theo's path and theo's at that
level
he's at that level he's at that level is
that the pinnacle you can't get higher
than that no he's uh he's yeah it's all
down for so he's like elvis yeah
yeah but he's eating peanut butter
sandwich he's gonna die on the toilet
but for me 80 pounds of feces
but for me it's about getting content
like the game has changed where you want
as much content as you can out possible
so i don't view specials like maybe theo
does or eric does i view it as marketing
what
is different
different folks is different you know
you might you could do a tour if you
wanted and say look i'm going on tour
and i'm going to do all my you know
certain classic bits if they have it or
that's why they're there to see i think
yeah some people might want to come and
see something specific it's definitely
better live no matter i think what it is
but
um
i don't know i'm probably doing i would
say 25
is the
is
is the
old stuff and
75 percent is new stuff so because he
just shot it when you think about so
it's tough to have a whole new hour
how long does it take to to get another
hour once your stuff's out there years
how do you guys do it how do you do that
that's why the game's so goddamn tough
eric how do you come up with new stuff
like well i'm always thinking about news
yeah i mean it just depends on it really
depends on the comic like how long
you've been doing it or if you trust
your point of view
you know i mean look at chappelle you
came out with seven specials in you know
three years or whatever it is so you
know what i mean so it's like it just
depends on the comic what you want to
talk about how you talk about it if you
understand your point of view then you
can talk about anything because people
are going to get that thing theo's got
that thing where you know so if you have
a subject his audience is going to be
like oh i can't wait to hear what theo
is going to say about this and they have
an idea
to go and his viewpoint on whatever it
is it's unique yeah he feels the most it
wasn't worth cha chappelle got that
money though
yeah yeah so he's got the emails all the
money they gave him you saw how they
released that info like he got 23 23
million
black people if y'all are out there if
y'all want reparations still
see dave maybe he got the cash
so when i got paid from those people the
game has changed
feels a bit special about quiznos i was
laughing at 5 45 a.m i woke up with my
son
the other little one still sleeping i
was laughing so hard on this quiz no bit
it woke my son up and then it's been
about when he he wants to get uh uh
funding for for college and he's a white
guy bro it's [ __ ] it's fantastic i loved
it theo
baby thank you bro i appreciate it man
thank you thanks for the support dude
even if i don't think you've been you
look like you've been doing steroids
[ __ ] made by yerba mate dawg
but thanks for the nice words man i'm
excited about it and i appreciate you
guys asking about it all right let's get
into it
here's the first kingdom
cause i'm an island boy
cause i'm an island boy
what up everybody i got a king of the
singer for you island boy
cause i'm an island boy
i'm trying to be an island boy
it's the newest song that's hitting the
nation it's a [ __ ] bop
can you understand it gang gang bust
nuts king king the the song sting the
way they look have you seen these dudes
no i don't know why i don't know what
you guys are talking about i'm an island
boy what is this what are you seeing
these two in uh
florida they're definitely florida
material really wait do you see it
they're hawaiian no no that's a hawaiian
song
yeah island boys hawaiian i wait do you
see them they're not hawaiian they're
hawaiian they're from another planet no
they're hawaiian they look like jamaican
hitchhikers kind of
no they look like jamaican takashi six
nines
i'm out on white boys with dreads i'm
out i don't think they're wrong
oh there you go okay i'm an island boy
and i've been trying to make oh i'm an
island boy
i i'ma just island boy i'ma just island
boy i'm gonna get kiwi
you're gonna keep that gun i'll be just
staring at the sun i'm using a full
gazing i'm like oh i'm staying they're
like you wanna be famous i'm trying to
be out oh great
please stop it you didn't like it
crazy they're tough to look at god
they're tough
dude there's holes to look at but it's a
catchy tune oh my god
if theo special doesn't like that this
is theo's next move
i'm a nashville boy that's hawaiian what
kind of style is that is that jamaican
hawaiian what is that couldn't tell you
never heard that that's their own thing
yeah and it is fire
it's the culture this is cultural
appropriation i feel like yeah
i guess i feel like i like suicide boys
this should just be suicide
[Laughter]
out who are you talking about you got
these white ass freddy douglasses out
here they don't know [ __ ] that's what
you got in this pool right here
i don't i don't i really don't know what
this i feel like an old man yeah i'm old
i don't know what's going on
this is just this reminds me of that
little girl who was on like the like uh
dr phil and she was yelling at hillary
holloway and she was yelling at her
parent her mom and she became a rapper
that baby what's her name baby oh baby
babe
these guys remind me of that catch me
outside girl
yeah yeah
so this is what i'm saying it's the same
kind of thing it's like you kind of hate
listening to this and then so they're
going to blow up look we're talking
about it on our podcast
yeah like i'm not going to listen to my
goddamn car but it i like that you like
the downfall of society
so that's a king and two stingets and
theo sting the way they look king the
way they sing
i would like to see both of these dudes
fight
nick diaz
that's what i would like and i think he
would do it
uh
i don't know man i don't know what's
going on here i feel like this is a side
effect of something that's happened in
society i think we're going to start
seeing more of it but no that's what
happened when mom when moms vape and
have babies man that's the side effect
yeah that's that great vape right there
they're already tatted they're like 16
years old they're so tattooed on the
chest and you're right they were raised
by their mother their dad died when they
were five and uh
one of them was asked if he if he wanted
to be a rapper he's like no i never
wanted to be a rapper growing up i just
wanted to be lit oh and
yeah i'd love to see their report cards
you're assuming they're in school yeah
yeah and they don't ever work hard
anymore man
they're doing away with those you saw
that in louisiana they just made a law
no more grades that make kids feel bad
and sad that's why i give my kid his own
grades
f
keep them humble you know f fine as hell
that little one i know that
[Laughter]
so that's a sting
what is the peak of these guys's um
career potential you're looking at it
you're looking at it no i totally don't
that could be their hits i think if they
like collab like takashi six nine dude
they would i would love that if they
collab with takashi six nine yeah show
it to my dad he just has a brain
aneurysm they just start telling on
people yeah just start snitching just
one
here's the thing all it takes is like
some
record exec
some money grubbing record exactly is
going to see that and be like oh
get them yeah and then they find some
producer who's got some tracks and they
just let them it's like millie vanilli
man you know they're just going to have
them do their thing and then the next
thing you know we're going to be like i
know all people keep saying is why are
these guys famous why are these guys
millions of millionaires and they don't
it don't even matter
i'm about to sign the thick boy records
i already got little brows i'll collab
with them in little brows you might have
to fight uh kodak black just reached out
mother [ __ ] yeah and he has the same
haircut he's the same haircut oh so he
sees the potential yeah no no he does
people see the dollar signs i'm a
nashville boy
what kind of boy are you stevie you say
it well they're calling us me and eric
soy boy
i'm a soy boy
i i don't know what that means though i
don't know what soybean a soy boy is i
so i said no soy boys that might yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so a soy boy is
someone that lacks masculinity like
someone who's real soft like woke up
so that's me i'm a soy boy you're not a
soy boy you're far from you're a sesame
boy i'm a sesame bar
because they're called amateurs
oh little [ __ ] who can't handle even
the slightest amount of pressure that's
not true man i that was pressure when
i've
who was calling when i took down george
who called you a sword boy you online on
my dms ah i keep going this way right
right
[Applause]
troll fans that two percent they're just
the loudest you don't don't don't worry
but don't stay out of their stuff that's
not gonna do any good we'll just stay
out yeah yeah i post i get out boom boom
you're still growing
you're still growing stevia i wouldn't
really put a lot of rules on yourself at
this age
at this age
but you but you look like
you're just like you look young yeah i'm
old but in korean years man you guys
you're like a damn turtle bro think
about you know yep if you got a little
they'll bust you open and find like 70
80 200 rings inside of your body bro
yeah man korean boys yeah koreans like
they look they look young until then
they turn into like you know it's like
cinderella yeah it's like like you put
them on a keychain at the end you put
them on a keychain
oh they still carved me i get carded oh
yeah you look young as [ __ ] man yeah
people at my show's like how old is
steve i'm like how do you think he is
like 26 27 like try 47. how do you know
my exact age i don't know i just assume
can we i don't know
everyone just have a joint funeral bro
theo act like
[Laughter]
what else you got nick uh this guy's
boy
this guy's got a relationship advice
question for us and i don't know he
might be in some trouble
stevie that dude from workaholics i got
a relationship advice for you let me
know what you think
you're dating this girl for about two
months
well then you can roast him because i
think he's in trouble yeah let's see
she had told me that the ex-boyfriend
was kind in the picture that had a
shared apartment together that he had
moved out of but he would come over
sometime to like do laundry because he
was still technically paying for it yeah
so it was a little messy but she told me
it was over um they were just kind of
involved in some day-to-day type things
that had been going on for a while and
so i kind of took her word on it but
then the other day she hits me okay that
she has to go to a wedding with him in
chicago we're in l.a
and we have to cancel our plans to go
see the great tim dillon together live
which makes it even worse but she claims
she just feels obliged to go because she
had already committed to going before
they broke up and now she's on a plane
to be fair a separate plane than him but
to go to the wedding with her
ex-boyfriend in chicago what are we
doing she claimed it's over she's just
doing it because she was already
committed to going but i'm not really
sure so what do you guys think get out
of there dude this sounds like this
sounds like a fish yeah i mean like not
a big deal yeah
can i take this one can i just throw
this in of course
it's taking this one he's washing his
whites doing the colors and getting his
dick sucked my man
yeah yeah when you break up with
somebody
you break up with them like you don't
have a shared apartment because first of
all it sounds like she ain't [ __ ] either
if she got an apartment you like like
what's going on with their apartment
that the ex-boyfriend's still paying for
it like it's time for you to get like
yeah you know sever that relationship so
if you still got a a a good enough
relationship with somebody that you're
still you know sharing bills
and he's still coming over to you know
what does he have so
is he knocking on the door or he's just
walking right in he's walking right you
know is she doing the laundry or is he
doing a lot is he picking the laundry up
you know what i'm saying like it sounds
like that relationship isn't over yet
and and he knows
don't be an idiot like you
you have to trust your instincts if you
feel like something's up something's up
oh bro he's dropping more than one load
off in that apartment you feel me all
right right that's something what are
you suggesting just get out
just
get up to the left to the left just get
out no
no i don't think i think you got to stay
in these days man you got to stay in
you got to let them fight at this point
everything is coming to battles yeah
you got people fist fighting everybody
people's stepmothers are out there fist
fighting on tick-tock big tiffany little
ernestine everybody fight you know so i
think you got to let these broads let
them hit get catch them videotape them
catch them it's a cheater situation yeah
you got to create yeah make controversy
get a hype tape or something so theo
should he fight should he fight homeboy
come over do his laundry try and get
this stain out of the white tee i would
get some footage of them yep i would put
it out on tick tock sell 30 40 tickets
do it over resume wait basketball can i
tell you something i ain't mad at the
dude coming over to do his laundry he's
being allowed to come over and do his
laundry like you call your ex and you go
hey can i come home and do laundry
should be like a real box i'll be like
get the [ __ ] out of here do no laundry
and then the fact that he's still paying
the fact that like it's like she's here
she's [ __ ] getting hate on him i'm a
better man like this guy right here
should be like yo i'm uncomfortable with
this situation oh it's minus six
thousand she's still sucking so you guys
have boundaries yeah thank you steve
boundaries
if you want the boundaries this dude
don't want him this dude's smiling he
got nice skinny i totally agree
tell me when you've got a cigarette burn
call me when one of your walls is
missing in your house he's a handsome
guy he can get another girl out there
like you first of all first of all let
me tell you something let me tell you my
lady ain't going to a wedding with her
ex the hell well how would you handle
that how would you say it first of all i
wouldn't be i wouldn't be in this
situation it wouldn't be a conversation
my girl wouldn't be like hey do you mind
your goddamn who's still coming
to them like an irrational calm manner
oh there's nothing rational about it but
get you out of your mind you grab her
elbow do i look like a sword
so you would hold her you hold your
elbow like you don't say no that's not
happening he ain't doing the laundry no
it's just first of all it wouldn't have
got to that point no
she never got out of that she never just
she never distangled herself
from her ex that's messy
i'm with theo i'd film that [ __ ] when
he get dropped his dirty laundry do that
security camera now i get on my cell
phone i go through his dirty undies he
got skid marks and [ __ ] i'm blasting
that on
what you do stevie stevie you hook a
gopro probably to
i would say i would do like a fake knee
injury knee injury knee brace gopro on
the side of it
wow
gopro in the laundry basket or in the
dryer he opens the dryer
right you gotta get that pov i like it
that's where i'm at that's that porno
yeah
evidence you need the evidence i mean
look what i no but there's no evidence
he already has the evidence he had
tickets to go someplace with his girl
and this girl's like hey we got to
cancel that i actually have to get on a
flight yes and go hang out with my ex
and they're going to stay in the same
room i've seen way too much cat no first
48 this is go ahead this guy is being
too soft man yeah here's what he wants
so that's soy boy stuff that's soy boy
boy stuff that's a soy boy tendency holy
smokes yeah stevie how would you handle
it you think case closed done done and
done boom done done tv going back home
to that black ass what's up girl
back by popular man we got some more
race my cases brought to us by eric from
60 years ago right here
[Laughter]
he's bringing us more race my cases
what up king and esteem crew judge
justin is [ __ ] back let's go
all right guys i got a funny one for you
guys today a man in arkansas was
arrested for indecent exposure after
police rolled into a neighborhood after
getting a call
about a dude
we'll get on to why they got a call
the guy was seen walking down the street
doing a couple of odd things so when
police rolled up on him they questioned
him hey man what are you doing down here
he said nothing much you know i just
walking around the neighborhood uh just
you know walking around the neighborhood
is what he said loitering they asked him
you know why did you know why did we get
a call down here about you uh possibly
exposing yourself he said well i saw a
dog using the bathroom that's the excuse
he gave do a naked car
a little bit more on the situation seen
that yep they found out that the dude
ended up
seeing a dog that wasn't even his
take a piss on somebody's lawn and
decided you know what i want to mark my
spot in this neighborhood too and pulled
his pants out pulled his dick out and
decided to try to pee he told the cops
hey i try i pulled my dick out i tried
to pee but nothing came out so i just
took the loss and kept it moving
race my case boys what guy is coming
through the neighborhood and trying to
pull out that old cocker spaniel i wish
i knew how big that dick was to be
honest it's probably pretty big that'd
make this a lot easier well yeah i mean
and it's the guy on drugs and what part
of the
story is was it was that a book report
justin what i don't even understand
what happened in the story i don't
either the guy was loitering in the
neighborhood the cops pulled out right
someone saw him pull his dick out well
after the dog took a piss because he
said i said the dog was taking piss why
can't i exactly oh yeah i think that's
fair man i think if a dog can do it you
should be able to do it yeah take a [ __ ]
dog um well you can't eat someone's
[ __ ] in public though theo yeah you
could
i've seen it
on a lot of stevie's uh i'm sure
private stock films you could
stevie
what race you you you go first what do
you mean what race do you really think
the pisser
what color is the guy that had his dick
out trying to oh he was a white guy i'm
gonna go with black arkansas
the cops came just because he's weird he
wasn't it wasn't
theo
white guy uh i don't i've never even
heard of an asian in arkansas i believe
fair point i'm gonna go
this sounds like such a white thing but
i'm gonna go black two black to white
two black to white what do we got nick
he was
black guy surprised that they didn't
call him first they didn't come get him
at the comedy store remember him
you know i don't know what neighborhood
he said you talked to the comedy store
what's his name doc doc yeah i'm staying
away from this yeah
stock willis
nfl fans you might be hungry for a big
week a big win you want to get something
good you want to you want the damn colts
to win somehow
that'll never happen
draftkings sportsbook it's an official
sports betting partner of the nfl that's
right
they got you covered
if you like to gamble if it's not a
problem for you if it's a problem for
you
don't do it
find something else to do call a friend
and i'm sorry that you're having to hear
this ad if this is a problem for you
but new customers who want a gambler my
friend tim yesterday said hey but i want
to put a few dollars on something
i said well maybe you know put ten
dollars on that josh allen
will run for two touchdowns
so he did that and he did derek henry
for two touchdowns
my boy j.a didn't get it done
derrick allen did
my buddy made like 200 bucks or
something awesome good for him
new customers can bet just five dollars
on any nfl team to win their game and if
they do you win 200 in free bets that's
right
winner winner
dinner
if that's simple
then it is simple
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state yet draftkings won't leave you
empty-handed everyone can play for huge
cash prizes
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at millions of dollars in
total prizes with their first deposit
yep download the draftking sportsbook
app now
now
use promo code k-a-t-s bet just five
dollars on any nfl team to win their
game and win 200 in free bets
that simple if they win you win with the
promo
code kats this week at draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana or pa only new
customers only minimum five dollar
deposit and one dollar wager required
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler okay
i got to let you know that this service
is available for clients worldwide
across the world full world
and that's beautiful
if you're chinese if you're japanese
black
asian black anise
germany's dude
if you're damn uh
philippine filipinegro
whatever you are you can get help
better help
they'll help you a broad range of
expertise is available you can do it on
phone through video conference all types
of ways
that's right visit their website and
read their testimonials a lot of great
ones
so many people have been using better
help they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states if you're
looking for work
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and king of the sting listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
kats i get help
you can if you need it
he's got another one yeah oh yeah oh
he's got another one right the same crew
so a mom in los gatos california
the cool mom was arrested for some crazy
[ __ ] i mean for or asian it means the
cash
sexual misconduct all sorts of different
[ __ ] but let me get into what she was
doing this lady was having crazy
uh sex parties crazy sex parties for her
for her kids i believe a 14 year old
white and a 15 year old two of her sons
and she would invite all of their
friends over and they would just drink
alcohol and she would encourage them to
have sex with the two girls that showed
up so imagine the real sausage fest that
was real gang bang but anyway uh some of
the kids spent the night some reports uh
say that they got so drunk there that
they were forced to go home and kind of
tell their parents what was going on and
then after that the lady would harass
the parents all this was going on in
california the lady knew that police
were catching up to her so her ass fled
to idaho and guess what this idaho
potato did this [ __ ] started having
more parties farm houses oh yeah i'm
just joking i don't know about that one
but ladies
she still had parties out there was
encouraging the same kind of behavior
with her sons the sheriff's office
basically said that her sons were in
danger and they arrested her and this
lady is gonna be facing some charges she
has a house in california worth four
point two million dollars
i don't know why that's vital and then
went to idaho just right throw that out
there
she had to blend in don't know yeah so
she got to be i tried to lay low and i
did all kinds of crazy [ __ ] race my case
boys
anybody not saying white white
theo white white white
it
white
it was doc willis
she's a white woman obviously oh there
she is yeah sandra o'connor so irish
foreign
how are these parties go like well she
would organize him they were in high
school saying that things do you say
like how can i get an invite yeah
how far is that from here
she's the best wing woman her son will
ever have yeah she's gonna do some time
so there are older women there no no
they're all teenagers that would be
different like imagine if she was
inviting her friends from book club
that's a difference to [ __ ] her son
that would be completely different but
this is just that would be bad too i've
seen a porno but this is just ridiculous
yeah like i i just find that ridiculous
it's like you want to like if you have
kids you just want to go like i don't
want you so you don't want your kids
going to anybody's house hell no you
know because you don't know what's going
on over there you don't know their rules
at that house i don't trust them phoebe
how would you handle it stevie uh
i would talk to my mom
and i would say mom this is not good
parenting
and uh
you're naked you're doing blow jobs
when you were a kid
you would have said that but then your
dad would have been like i would have
said
i would say mom this is not right
um and i take my brother and we what are
you wearing when you say this yeah
you're just in your i wouldn't close i
would be close the hell you would be
what do you mean this these are your
problems yeah
no but he wouldn't be talking to his mom
naked he wouldn't come in the house like
mom guess what i just got finished doing
at my friend's house so the everyone in
the house is naked yeah it's a gang bang
dude it's a gang bang of high school
kids
i wouldn't let it get to that point i
swear to god i wouldn't let it get to
that point right chin right i remember
would you be like a referee no i just
could get i would leave the house you
wouldn't film it yeah i would have my
clothes on and i would just leave the
house good for you better man
so at 15 you would have came in
don't push it don't push the issue
though i'm just saying you know what you
wouldn't you're pushing you're paying my
payments
i gave you my answer you're pushing the
issue okay
you are pushing them
[Laughter]
here's a question i have for you stevie
say you're the parent okay you're the
mom or the uh trans dad or trans mom
yeah
and they come in and they say hey
uh and your kids come in they say hey
stevie mom stevie
we're tired of doing all the sex we're
tired of all of this
what do you do as a mom
as their mom yeah you're that lady
that's throwing the parties and you and
you're letting your two friends i would
respect their decision i'd be like all
right fine i'll take this party
elsewhere
boom okay this actually leads into our
next debate club it's about some uh
he's looking for some advice how to
parent
hey guys it's aaron out of indiana
what's your opinion on something so
growing up my parents kept me in the
dark a lot on things like sex and drugs
didn't work at all though because i
absolutely love [ __ ] and i did a lot of
drugs thankfully not anymore i have two
kids now though and i believe that they
need to know about these kind of things
when they're younger so they can grow up
knowing what's going on around them they
don't make the same mistakes i made
what's your opinion what would you do i
love this show guys i watch it every day
at work gang gang buzz buzz peace out
boys
baby hit it brandon you're the one with
kids go ahead brendan yeah i'm with him
i grew up being pretty uh exposed to
everything cussing sex
dark [ __ ] pies yep moon pies drugs
twinkies nah not drugs because sports
kept me out of drugs
i was aware of it
yeah uh josta beverly
yep
but uh
yeah like i'll let my kid watch damn
near anything unless it's scary because
then he won't sleep but
you know obviously not sexy and stuff
like that but we get
a certain age i definitely want to have
to talk with them well i think you don't
make it weird i think what this guy's
talking about is like at what point do
you talk about these things and how do
you talk about or do you just keep your
kids away from it and i'm of the belief
and i used to work with kids myself so i
understand like they're gonna do things
so it's like i think it's about giving
them the tools to be able to handle
these situations and process you know
process like so for instance like you
know it's like if a high school party
you want to tell your daughters
especially your daughters like hey don't
drink alone like if if you're gonna go
do these things make sure you know the
people don't take drugs from someone you
don't know don't drink at a place where
you don't know the people you don't feel
safe you gotta have a buddy goldilocks
dude who's wandering into somebody's
house drinking at
you'd be surprised man there's a whole
documentary on netflix about this about
these young girls who ended up uh you
know getting raped at these parties
you know and then not being not being
believed you know what i mean all i'm
saying is like don't put yourself in a
situation yeah you don't know what's
going on yeah but do you go to parties
all the time when you're in high school
someone's like hey we're going to go to
so-and-so's party you think it's cool
and you're there and while you're there
the people are like hey we're drinking
you want a drink it's like i'm just
saying give them the tools to make sure
that they're careful make sure you know
you're not going to stop them from
knowing no that's why you can say you
got to be realistic yeah be realistic
yeah yeah be real so give them the tools
to survive what's the age you talk give
them this talk what's the age i think
it's like early teens man early just
like being great dude yeah even though
they're about to enter high school
exactly eighth grade i think they're
about to be around other people i think
and once they're about to be around
other people that's when it's time to be
like hey these kind of things happen
because you don't know what's going on
look for instance your kid could be
going to school with
that other kid whose mom is having sex
parties correct so you don't know what's
going on that kid's coming back being
like oh i did this this but so it
wouldn't be a good example like again i
used to work at a school so it's like
you know when you have a kid and you're
one of these people that's like i don't
want my kid to have a cell phone
and then you know what i mean and then
they go to school and all the kids get
cell phones
you setting them up to be like well why
am i different from everybody else and
all that stuff so it's about i think
it's really religious i think it's about
talking about the religious i think it's
about talking about things
like you're talking about dog it's it's
like cussing like
my grandma was british as [ __ ] so they
cussed all the time so they didn't like
hide me from the cussing i just knew
when to do it when not exactly so that's
what i do with my son like i cuss i have
a whole ben i cuss man
he'll like throw some words here and
there but never in school never around
his grandma i'm like if you're around
your friends you can you can use
whatever language you want really but if
you're around like people you respect
you can't talk like this but but that
what you're talking about right now is
like that's the responsibility let me
ask you a question what if your son when
he's in high school right like sophomore
junior year yep and he goes dad like we
want to
drink and party
um yeah
get a couple beers yeah
would you allow him to do that if it was
if he had supervised the whole like they
drank at home
you know what you're saying
like hey dad we'll leave the cash you
don't want to be that cool dad who's
like hey i'll buy the beers come home
yeah we don't know what this is about
you though it's about like knowing
you're knowing you're from the kid's
friend's parents correct it's about a
community so you would tell their
parents say i'm going to get a keg
we're going to put it in the garage okay
you just went from a couple of beers to
like
should they get some hookers too no no
no no but they want to do that because
they're homies with their friends with
their friends no they want to drink beer
no i'm with them at your home they're
safe yeah i know you know what i'm
saying that's a tough situation but
again you you don't want to you can't do
this if like one of the parents is like
what are you doing because they're right
yeah they're right so i understand if
you're if your future if it's your
favorite your cousins go ahead theo
because we can't see you but go ahead
i'm a green
i'm a green cube but i'm still a human
okay
i've always been applied as a green cube
but you're just an s
oh sorry from here it just looks like a
green cube
you're just a blue s yeah yeah
i've never come out and said it before
but i want to say it now i'm a blue s
and
i think if you have the kids over to the
house and you get a keg or a pony keg i
think stevie is the place to start one
of them baby kegs you know the mini kids
um
i think it's okay if the kids drink at
the house under adult supervision i just
don't think you should let them drive
home unless you breathalyze the kids
fair point right
so you have to have a breathalyzer at
home yeah that makes a party fun at
breathalyzer yeah yeah yeah they're just
gonna be like
drunk
you know what it's like
it's a nuanced conversation because
there's one side where you go
uh you know
you can't do this you know and then
there's the other side where you're just
like well i want if they're going to do
it
i want to be the one in charge of it
yeah what my dad did because he knew i
was going to drink when i was going to
high school and you know i wanted to get
a scholarship to play division 1 sports
and he was like you can do whatever your
friends are doing their [ __ ] round do
that but the people you respect don't do
that they're focused on this thing so
you can do that and have fun but you're
not going to get here it's up to you go
ahead and do that and i never did it you
know what it's about just whatever it is
it's about presenting my choices
i never touched it till really i got out
of college
i never started drinking good for you
really never come on i want to get
places
yeah in the garage we had a fridge i
would just take his miller lights and
yeah hell yeah me and stevie almost
overdosed you little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah
your kid comes to you boy i'll [ __ ]
tickle you boy
um should i do it for you your kid comes
to you and asks you it's time he says
daddy i'm getting you know
i'm getting some my pants is getting
hard i'm seeing titty on girls
how do you what do you teach them what
do you tell them you got thir you got 30
seconds give your kid the talk go well i
would teach him first how to masturbate
um i would say if you're getting those
feelings and then oh i'll take him to
the hustler's store i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't talk guys i'll take
him to the hustler's store let me finish
i want to know how he's going to teach
you so we want to roll back
it can we button that
i need to know how he's going to just
believe it
it's my son okay but you're like son
this is how you do it and you lead by
example yeah
so he would sit next to me just like how
bobby thought
he would sit next to me and i'd go um
hey uh uh let's say his name's brian
i go hey brian so take off all right sit
over there oh wow
over here and then maybe put on like a
movie
what do you mean do this no keep going
let him have his let him have it is his
son so let's say this is a flashlight
and i would teach him how to lube it and
i would say
and then i would say hey son this is how
you do it no okay and then that okay
what i like is in steve's house he's
gonna have like a cabinet that's gonna
open up like oh
i thought i thought you know he's gonna
be like your son
like no pregnancies and then he'll learn
how to bust nuts okay
safe safe and more safe you're like son
you thought that was a gunshot in that
little tea bag dawg you gotta nun chuck
them in that little tea bag boy okay
let's do this though let's say though
you're sitting there with your son
and you know you're ready to get the
fleshlight you look over
[Laughter]
you going to teach me yeah fear that you
cut i have fear that you caused me to be
fearful
then i would like to that's when i kind
of kill myself i i can't wait to hear
theo's kid when he asks you and that's
how they do it yeah
you kill yourself in the appropriate
forest or whatever dude be
go back to your roots you're like a
freaking boss you know what i'm saying
give me something so if there's a penis
jump you pound it dog yeah
on the side of the tv if his penis is
there it is three inches and my penis is
like a vienna sausage like this uh-huh
yep
yeah i'd be so depressed i don't know he
says pound it doug boom
there it is so that that that would be a
deep depression i'd fall in okay
okay
your son comes home he throws off his
ghee he's got oil all over his body
okay
how do you teach him about sex you got
30 seconds to talk to him
how old is he huh like right now your
son your kid i don't know when was he
born he's five dude i'd be so disturbed
with you all oiled up and he's in prison
like his dad he's got four horses being
delivered outside oh i got one for you
too brendan you're running out of time i
got another one for you bro
okay wait yeah answer theaters first
answer theo there's no question i would
drive down to that [ __ ] jiu jitsu gym
whoever oiled him up and beat the [ __ ]
out of everybody what do you got stevie
so your son when he's 13 years old he
goes hey dad which what's one your son's
name tiger of boston okay uh hey hey
it's tiger right whatever yeah hey dude
forgot i found this weed
um do you mind if i roll a joint and
i'll just smoke it in the backyard and
he's never done it before yeah he's 13
yeah i would say the same thing my dad
did like you can do that you can get
really sick you can do that but what you
cause he's really into sports he loves
like tom brady and lebron james and i'll
tell them those guys aren't doing that
so he can do that and people like
diana's brothers did it
they train like that right
when they're high they sure triathlon
sure i don't want my kid to be the diaz
brothers but that's what they say to you
when your kid says to you but i want to
be like the diaz brothers well if my kid
goes i'm an island boy i'd be like god
damn dude well i i failed as a parent
well i still have the visual of brendan
have his kid in his hand and he goes
down to the gym and he's like who oiled
up my stuff
who in the hell oiled up
you know
and they're just like
that's the scene i want to see play out
yeah
who been oiling up my boy
hell yeah dude and look it's all it's a
big bellator backstory is what it ends
up coming
okay eric your turn 30 seconds your son
comes up to you he doesn't know he's
probably he could be trans he could be a
piano player we don't know you don't
know those are the choices trans or
piano player got it got it
go uh
and he comes up and he says dad there's
something i don't know what's going on i
feel like
i may be ovulating i might have an
erection
and i've been looking at porn what do
you tell them
this is natural
you know your bodies react to the
opposite sex or sometimes the same sex
and it's a natural feeling that you have
and uh you know go explore that
that's your honest answer yeah i don't
want to make it you don't want to make
your kids you don't want to make your
kid feel weird about anything
everybody's got 20 seconds to go you
know what i mean
you take them to a park or something do
you guys make it like a like a not a but
like a thing where you know a lot of in
native cultures and you know this
probably some of you guys maybe stevie
maybe uh full of patchy doug nobody else
but yeah brennan said he's apathy but um
where sometimes the father someone will
go into the woods and the they'll teach
the kid they'll beat his one of his
teeth out with a little
thing and then he'll ejaculate or
whatever and then he comes back a man
that's the weirdest one this is where
this is that's insane what you just said
this is where theo's from yeah that's
actually new orleans his dad took him
from the trailer yeah that's that new
orleans [ __ ] man and by woods he meant
the back of the trailer park
you know what i mean right by the the
shared barbecue pit you know the shells
gas station yeah yeah yeah yeah and
nicholas google uh teeth father knocks
out teeth for uh i googled right now
this is real his tooth
what
he's not lying i know it was rooted in
some sort of truth
yeah it's called the tooth fair you sick
right of passage
look we made it a lot easier and we made
it gay friendly by calling it that this
was the real boys they went into the
woods and they would ejaculate and knock
out the tooth
i don't know
you don't know that's insane okay and
you're standing next to your son and
both you guys have oil all over your
bodies and you're yelling at people at a
freaking open at an open man
[Laughter]
wait when did we get oiled up
in the story everybody
how is everyone in the theo's story
everybody's oily you know what i mean
they either they're trans or piano
players and they're oily but you gotta
take theo's advice with a grain of salt
he lost his virginity and he was getting
rocks thrown at him you feel me what
really yeah
yeah yeah yes sir at a bowling alley
behind a bowling alley tiffany lane
shout out tiffany lane's bowling alley
still open new carpet they just put on
the sign out front
was that is that brought to you by
theovon
like his pictures inside the bowling
alley and it was like it should yeah
this is the yeah the theolon center you
know
what i'm saying
and stevie would be old stevie's got
probably so much aster i bet you would
test positive for astroglide if you just
spit in a cup right now stevie oh we
can't let theo off the hook though your
theo your son comes home he's definitely
trans yes he asks you about sex go ahead
nick she has mascara on he goes dad i've
been looking at these butts and i can't
get enough of them 30 seconds on you
theo go
i would say look son you look beautiful
son child
you know your mom left us and so
a lot of this [ __ ] is her fault
fair that's fair
but we're still here together man you
know us you know i i sometimes i do
masturbation in my room if you need to
do something do i would suggest you do
it in your room
uh if you want to do it outdoors i could
drive out to a park or something you
could do it outdoors and i love you not
in the comments that's pretty good best
answer yeah theo nailed that
oh
man
i don't know if he nailed it
because he's like the ballpark because
china would have already said uh don't
call me son yeah you know he was like so
he already messed up pronouns are there
them dad you know theo already
somebody rank us somebody rank us
somebody right
laughs
yeah
i'm sorry stevie you can't masturbate
with your son next to you
i know but this is korean brother that's
just not dude that is betraying you're
going to jail dude
i'm just looking at the scenarios
unbelievable just a scenario unfreaking
believable dude everything is
unbelievable outraged
wow this is this is what you said you
portrayed me dude you betrayed all the
things that said stephen
i didn't know you were korean yeah
oh my god i'm hurting dude after the
show he's like
can we speak
family wholesomeness it's very difficult
it is hollywood okay
hollywood
i rest my case wow what's this guy what
nick uh this is uh king of their stint
what's up cats crew this is nathan
coming to you from frisco texas
uh tell us
or sting at the throat to you guys so
i grew up as an only child uh spent a
lot of my summers indoors watching the
game show network so that
is probably a good part of the reason
why i have uh braces as an adult at 26.
um but one of the hidden swims from that
time period is 25 000 or 100 000 pyramid
i was a big fan brendan i know you've
been hitting the head a lot so i don't
know if you
can count quite that high maybe not as
big of a fan but still wanted to to
throw it out there king it or sting it
25 000 100 000 pyramid
gang gang buzz buzz my favorite thing
about those shows was like when they
would go to commercial break the lights
would sort of dim and then all of a
sudden like big conversations would
break out yeah like real [ __ ] yeah they
would just be like they would the guy
would be like
yeah they like fake it yeah talk so i
used to love that stuff i don't remember
the show i can't comment i don't
remember it you didn't watch tv i grew
up on uh wheel of fortune jeopardy
family food
i i know those
yeah see for me it was dating game
newlywed game you know i'm older so it's
like those of those oh the price is
right too the price is right
family feud if i'd missed school i used
to i used to love walking around yeah
right you were watching parties
yelling at people
uh well we actually stevie can check out
the game and see if he likes it because
we have a 25 000 pyramid built for you
too i think we could go eric and brendan
versus stevie and theo [ __ ] you hoes and
chin or right now right now yeah it'll
be the house how do you how does it how
do you play yeah you have to answer
questions yeah chin i'll explain it once
yeah uh um is chin on my team no you're
with theo you're what you are there i
think you guys already realize he's not
yeah he already rejected your team yeah
he wants nothing to do with you he
doesn't want your pissy kitchen sink or
your
oh you're shitty
those are chin's words
in a couple of years he's going to
change the last letter of his name to a
p is going to be chip
[Laughter]
i love you guys good to see you today
stephen hell yeah man we're having a
good time huh
yeah i had a dream the other day about
you actually you were selling um
blankets or something in it does that
ring a bell
no it doesn't
steel said that like his dreams are
clairvoyant i'm an island boy
deal i'm pumped for you man with that
netflix special brother congratulations
man
killing it thank you man killing it
do you feel different do you feel
different do you think you're better
than us
no uh i thought that earlier but i think
i'm fine now
makes sense
uh chin bring us in all right thank you
nick this is the king and the sting
pyramid seen here every thursday right
here on youtube or heard wherever you
get your podcasts
let's meet our first team
eric griffin and brendan shobb now
brendan i hear you've been struggling
with your weight a little bit
yet you have a show dedicated to food is
that true part of the prom yeah food
truck diaries there you go okay great
eric i have to know what was it like
working on with or what was it like
working with the workaholics guys it was
great good dudes
that's fantastic
those guys are hilarious now let's meet
our second team theo
it says here you beat autism
well i beat it the first time
he's in the third round right now with
it and we discussed it
definitely uh it's that tyson it's that
tyson wilder bro that fury wilder so
he's coming back yeah teddy
and uh we discussed this earlier but i
understand you have a netflix comedy
special can you tell us a little bit
more about that
uh yep i do and it's on uh on telev on
netflix you can check it out man and um
that's it that's all this it should be
exciting i hope it is
it is exciting and now
stevie let's see
stevie
i hear you recently parted ways with an
artificial
disturbing tiny ass
that you that's used to simulate sex i
imagine that was pretty hard
yeah man there's a lot of growth in that
you know what i mean i'm proud of them
there's a lot of growth in that all
right so as long as there's growth
mastery in a different way i don't have
as many toys
more traditional more traditional yes
any more questions no okay great all
right so now that we got to know the
contestants a little bit let's get
started today's categories are
thick heroes
the con test
cats kryptonite
the great outdoors
let's play make believe and laugh track
each category has seven answers
and one partner will have 45 seconds to
describe all seven answers as a person
guesses
as the other person guesses i mean
anytime you're allowed to pass
and once you get to the end you get you
can go back to the beginning and try any
you passed on after two rounds the
winning team will will play the pyramid
nick and i are going to be oh nick and i
are going to do a quick practice round
to show you guys to show you an example
our fate category
is famous asians
this is oh no this what does it say this
is asian this asian people
oh this is asian people that are famous
this is asian people that are famous
nick will be giving me the clues let's
put 45 seconds on the clock and
go
god he's gay and was in star trek
uh
to cut george takai right yep uh he was
a baseball player for the new york
yankees they called him uh godzilla uh
i'm gonna [ __ ] this up
you can pass pass see this is learning
we're learning um uh he's he was in
parks and recreation and like a lot of
people don't think of this as asian but
it is technically asian india come on
now no but the guy the guy yeah i know
he's from india yeah uh oh uh the
freaking god damn i was even sorry yes
uh
it's this example he's the father of
martial arts
bruce lee yep uh
martial arts you're that black guy that
went to my high school
he was in community and ken chung yes uh
we got five out of seven all right five
seconds
that's how it works that's how that
works so who goes first uh we will just
say brennan and eric can go first you
can select the camera i'll do thick
heroes
fake heroes oh man so i'll there's a
little bit more detail after you pick
the uh thing
so in the car brendan
so thick heroes these are famous
fat or thick people
uh now who will be giving you or who
will be giving and who will be receiving
the clues i'm get i'm i'm giving you're
giving yeah he's the boss you're the
receiver okay you got 45 seconds and go
uh he's a buddy of ours he does a uh
podcast two beers in the cave burt
crusher the other one
uh oh uh
yeah
um he was the prime minister of england
he was a warrior william thatcher nope
he's a prime minister oh no um um oh no
come on what'd i say i messed his name
up uh i forgot
yeah you can pass uh
not cardi b has a thick ass she's from
houston
oh uh nicki minaj nope the other one [ __ ]
she sings the [ __ ] song with cardi b oh i
don't know
[ __ ] me uh the other one for two beers
in a cave not tom burt christian yep uh
she has a fat ass she's uh uh dating uh
ben affleck jennifer lopez yep uh he was
on i flew him out he came in here he
wrestled stevie oh man
oh my god i forgot his video
[ __ ] i forgot the kid's name i'm sure
he's got to be george let me make the
stallion i don't know rap like that
she's a savage uh mega stan
i said [ __ ] that's nicki minaj yeah it
was bad no it's not oh that's
like they did about me did it okay
they're four four i believe right yeah
you're right man you guys did pretty
good man they're pretty good for you
guys okay right uh i gotta look all
right i got you theo you ready
hold on which uh which let's play make
believe all right let's these are some
things people think don't exist
all right you guys are ready who's going
to give who's receiving i'm doing i'm
going to give you yeah and then theo
listen up okay all right well we have 45
seconds on the clock and
go
okay this is a horse with the horn on
its forehead
ooh um
halloween no uh uh sorry a horse with a
horn a magical horse with a horn
carnival horse come on bro dude think
more mythical
oh uh unicorn thank you
um
this is if you meet a woman you might
say this to her after 10 years you are
my guy
you are my something something
a sunshine
yeah
you are my something something you love
this person
for eternity
eternity partner pass
read faster dude okay three seconds
people pray to this when they get on
their knees
you can count it yeah all right that's
two things you guys did or didn't get
winston churchill you didn't winston
churchill that's what they did yesterday
he said thatcher okay so it's actually
three to two three to two three three to
two damn that's the one i forgot all
right eric you're up with the new guys
[Laughter]
the contest okay does this even mean so
the contest these are words that start
with con
c-o-n so 45 seconds on the clock and
go
uh a criminal
gun
uh
they're in jail convict boom
um it's the it's uh
they want to tear down the statues uh it
was on the it was on the top of the
general lee and uh
it's outside of theo's door yeah oh
confederate yeah
but it's a wave there boom
i don't know if the fight got the napkin
it's a city next to it's a uh estate
next to new york boom
uh theo never uses him when he has sex
not so fast
more erections
keep going
when
the
uh she was working with uh george bush
black
uh
uh oh oh [ __ ] steve likes to eat this
bass give me one more uh
you live in uh
boom yes
i think it's unfair that theo was
talking to renard
jokes and [ __ ] yeah when you didn't get
unicorn yeah all right so it is uh five
three and two uh it is eight to two
right now
now now theo actually will give to
stevie he has the same cards in front of
him okay let's go buddy you can pick
between
cats kryptonite the great outdoors laugh
track
i think that's it oh yeah those three
yeah great outdoors
okay good luck stevie okay wait see
which one you pick clear outdoors great
great outdoors all right so these are
things that are outside
45 seconds on the clock hold on hold on
one second hold on all right and go
okay they fly in the air and they can
poop downward
you say it again a gli
a glider
but it makes us it makes a squawking
noise
[Music]
they fly in the air stevie a [ __ ]
bird helicopter
[Music]
these are um the women that you don't
care about that are always over there
putting on lip gloss and talking [ __ ]
a newer term for it oh thoughts
oh nice okay if somebody doesn't have a
place to live and they live outdoors
what do you call them homeless got it
all right got it okay it's bumper to
bumper all these traffic traffic traffic
bumper to bumper truck okay it's a it's
a it's a lesbian or a man that brings
out postage to your house
last one mail woman
mailman
all right so that's four man so uh
eight to six it was going pretty i was
only gonna do two rounds so this is
going pretty well i think we finish out
the category man hey man let me help let
me talk about partner for a second
think about it let's go think about it
think about what you're about to say
think of something that's in the air
it's birds
and takes a [ __ ] he said hang glider i
mean horse with a horn though yeah the
unicorn
okay okay all right
are we tired it's eight to six you guys
are six so the uh
so we'll actually have theo or and
stevie go so we know if they have a shot
to win um since they're behind because
if you guys get too many then but if we
only get two no let them go that's fair
let them go no let's try and dominate
yeah let them go yeah they could
dominate yeah yeah yeah yeah let's blow
them out of the water
kryptonite cat's kryptonite all right
these are things that all right so cat
script tonight is these are things that
we all struggle with
45 seconds on the clock we all like us
here yeah everybody every human one
person that struggles with it but
someone in here struggles with it all
right 45 seconds on the clock and hard
category go no it's not this is easy uh
if you eat too much food you're always
trying to lose weight yep uh theo loves
to snort this coke yep
uh
yeah one thing for stevie he needs to
have more what on stage
uh jokes yeah but he needs to be stage
time no he needs to have this in life uh
more
humor pass pass all right uh
um when you do better when you and your
girl are talking she goes we need to
have better communication yep um theo
also struggles with this he has to go to
uh therapy for it because he likes to do
this with women uh sex yep
um
sex but if you do it all the time you
have a problem you would have a sex
addiction yep boom time all right that's
only four four wow you guys are good uh
12 to six you guys need six out of seven
to tie seven perfect game to win
oh this should be
it's laughs hey don't don't jump the
clock don't jump the clock
don't jump the clock give me a second so
i can look so laugh track you can yeah
laugh truck so laugh track these are
famous sitcoms
wow oh famous sitcoms let me know when
you're ready stevie
even
five
four
three
two
this is a man's name that
that rhymes with rave
us dave we're going to count it no more
rhyming
that's right um this is um you must be
ridiculous
we're
oh eric's on the show
he used to be on the show
no no he was on a tv show it was called
workaholics oh uh
uh mr belvedere
uh all right eric griffin and brenda
shaw let me let me try to do this baby
let me try to do this with uh uh theo do
not ever be my partner again
theo let's
kirk cameron oh god i also had small
wonder on there theo i like really
played oh man
i'll let you down maryland i'll let you
down small wonder with the robot we're
talking about kyle dunn again uh isn't
it my turn
you guys want one
we beat the [ __ ] out of them all right
all right don't rub it in you did
theory
netflix day but what's up bro so sorry
theo
okay it happens man you know it's hard
to uh i'll let you know i think i'll let
you know i want to believe stevie tried
his best i tried dude
you guys are just better
i wanted to win i did too
thanks for tuning in to the king of the
sting
the the appearance to you the period one
is harder like to for the descriptions
yeah yeah yeah and those were tough yeah
but that the game itself was fun yeah we
beat the [ __ ] out of you guys
dysfunctional team over there yeah
uh should we close it out with another
king it or sting it yeah last one
all right yeah
theo's lost all energy
he's a competitor he's [ __ ] pissed
i wanted to win i don't know it's my
fault
it's my fault i'll get i'm going to buy
you a smoothie next time you come in he
wasn't ready get your smoothie
what does this look like okay
who is that you don't know what it looks
like what
no one knows
[Music]
i know a lot yeah yeah he does
it's pretty it's pretty spot on chin
whispered
he does look like him a little bit a
little
uh
public restrooms uh
i'm here at the dorms so
bathroom situation there's about 40 of
us using three stalls oof
and it's quite nasty the other day
somebody well
they were doing that dirty
must had some casserole or something
from the calf
i don't know but uh
must have ran out of toilet paper they
used some of them paper towels
what i would do when i was in college
because they don't give you a bathroom
they give you a sink i just piss in the
sink all the time
yeah god hell yeah felt free
nothing felt more fun i just think it
felt like this is like you have to have
some kind of talk you know it's like you
have to have like dorm meetings
with all those savages
and then we're going to have like a like
here's the talk ball so only you can
only talk about it
this isn't harvard this is la community
college people taking shits all over the
place
oh you can walk on campus
[Laughter]
you're trying to have a talk with
everybody dude these people are future
opioid addicts okay all right you're not
eating out of the buggy
you have to sting it and you just hope
it works out you know what i mean bring
your own baby wipes no i think
bring it you know you go away
plan these things you you write some
stuff on the stall walls that are going
to keep certain types of people out of
certain stalls yeah you are you i think
you do things to to kind of mark your
territory a little bit yep or you give
those oatmeal uh cream pies you know hey
man every tuesday at six o'clock that
stalls mine here's your cream pie
oh baby wipes yeah it's like christmas
i'm saying you have your own baby you
want your own baby wipes you can wipe
down the toilet with your own baby wipes
yeah it's a nightmare either way yes is
that it brother that's it yeah all right
man dallas november 11th through the
13th shooting my 30 minute special buh
buh
november 4th and 5th in la i'll have
info for you guys soon on that this will
be a special night too uh we'll have
news for that what do you got here yeah
i'm at the arlington draft house uh this
weekend great friday and saturday love
it
youtube.com scissor bros subscribe today
theo vaughn netflix special is out
yeah check it out on uh on twit on uh
on netflix on it on your platform and
just you know like it tell people to
watch it and then i'll be in charleston
and asheville this weekend oh we just
opened up some tickets for coachell uh
in coachella california at a casino out
there on december 4th so that's a spirit
casino i think nice stevie i don't know
if you've been out there that'd be fun
no i haven't been out there
sure a lot of your grandparents have
been out there but um
it's a beautiful casino out there in the
desert and it's a good place since i'm
looking forward to seeing you guys out
there maybe stevie will come out there
and make why don't you come out there
and do five minutes yeah yeah yeah
i'm writing some stuff theo just give me
yeah i got him coming november first i'm
writing him he's gonna come to a show at
the lab at the improv he's gonna come to
three minutes there i'm starting to
write so we're doing it we're going
we're going to get this going i just got
to get thrown in the pool i've been
writing i'm writing love it this one
you might be ready
maybe i don't know either way i have
yeah you'll be ready you got to do it
you've got a lot of time the theo is
giving the opportunity okay okay yeah
yeah i hit the notebook i'll hit the
notebook there you go okay all right
guys love it we're out
there take care guys
[Music]
i gotta go in and go hard in the paint i
do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino brendan ate the queso and
the case of ritos but everything's gonna
be fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and i'm feeling incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]